well today I want to talk data mining
which is what I'm really interested in
and I want to explain a little bit about
the inner workings of data mining a
little bit of a sort of terms that you
might have heard when you really first
lecture or the first book I want to talk
about supervised learning unsupervised
learning what exactly are these things
and then I want to get on to something
new semi-supervised learning and also
what's the research at the moment in
this area
it's called machine learning that's the
sort of phrase that applied artificial
intelligence machine learning if you get
our data we want to mine the data and
broadly there's kind of two categories
of methods how this works so if I could
pull up my prop yes I've carefully
prepared here are some items of data
that I have brought along the first
method maybe that I should explain is
unsupervised learning because it perhaps
the easier way it's called unsupervised
learning because we don't have any
examples that are labeled so it's a
unlabeled learning I guess the idea is a
supervisor knows the answer and we don't
have anybody who knows the answer so we
get the data to begin with and we don't
really know anything about it we know
obviously the attributes we know the
values but we don't know what categories
are they let's say that's a problem
so I'm supervised learning very often is
the sorting off the data so you get your
first date item and you put it somewhere
and then comes another data item and you
basically go let's do colors is this
similar is it different and now this is
quite different we put it there and then
comes another date item oh it's this
similar is it different it's a little
bit similar to the yellow ones were put
it'll be closer to the yellow one and
then comes another data item and no this
is obviously quite similar to the yellow
one to be put it closer to here and then
so over time you get all these data
items in and they might end up a bit
like something maybe a bit like that so
what have I done have done a sorting of
the data and the approach I've done is
something based on similarity measures
these unsupervised methods they all we
use the similarity measure in this case
I've done kind of by color the other way
these methods usually work is to
actually start out by saying well how
many groups would you like your data to
be in how many clusters would you like
to be in so let's say you want them in
three clusters well there may be
solution might look like this it's
clustered by the color three clusters if
there would have been four clusters
maybe the solution but it looked like
this and if there was maybe two clusters
it might
even looked like this so you might ask
okay so so what's the data mining about
the sorting of the data
well once we sorted the data in this way
we can of course have a look at also
what ended up together maybe these
things have ended up together and maybe
now we can say oh this is the light
colors this is the dark colors and we
certainly have two groups I mean
wouldn't normally sort color cubes you
would say sometimes or patients and are
they really a lot very ill and you know
that sort of thing and we could sort
about this now
most of the unsupervised methods Berg
exactly like I described so the worker
by sorting it the differences that how
to measure the difference between things
so is it a statistical similarity is it
a algebraic similarities that you're
metric measure you can imagine or so
many ways you can measure the difference
between things unsupervised learning is
sort of quite a simple way of doing it I
mean just quite quick the algorithms but
it's not as powerful as other methods
what's the problem with it but one of
the problems with it is actually quite
straightforward let's say we end up with
this solution well this is a good
solution or it's not a good solution
it's actually really hard it's really
hard to evaluate because we obviously
don't know about a data we don't know so
we're looking at it going which looks
okay but maybe not and then very often
what happens actually if you look at the
data from one way it looks like a good
solution but now I do my reveal we sort
of turn the data a bit and you know
suddenly we have another angle on the
data and like actually now it's a mess
they're not really sorted variable
anymore are they well often what happens
unsupervised learning you sort them in
one way and they look quite good but
then we look at the data differently and
actually this hasn't quite worked and
it's not so great the other downside
with unsupervised learning is the
algorithms really only work when you
tell them how many groups you want the
data to be in two groups three groups or
groups and for some problems you might
notice maybe you have like I say ill
patients and healthy patients and you
know there is two groups but very often
actually how many groups you have is the
whole question so you can't really use
these methods of well if you want to
know some technical terms
k-means for example it's a classic
unsupervised methods that's very popular
so if you can look double up and you'll
then learn a bit more about it now
secondly of doing learning would be the
supervised the way we said unsupervised
there must be that must be a supervisor
vein here the difference is that you
have some data which has some answers
attached to it already so you can learn
from this data really learn from it and
a classic way of doing it is to very
well know neural networks it's one of
the best known ones how does that work
okay well so have some date again and
this time let's say we want to do
something a bit different we want to
just sort them in light colors and dark
colors for example and what happens is I
get my data in and already somebody has
labeled the later meter said these are
light colors these are bar colors so we
already know the answer for this data we
don't know it for some other data but we
know it for this this is our training
data and now I'm going to do a new
learning manual network the first data
item comes in it goes here the next day
it occurred item comes in and goes here
and I'll keep doing this and maybe I end
up with something that looks like this
and now of course now then I can I can
assess the quality of the solution
because and go well algorithm you've
done okay but you haven't done it really
well because these two should be over
there this one should really be there
fix the function that they didn't do it
again okay back and we might end up like
this it's like okay I was better but you
still got one wrong fix the function
again and do it again so this is called
back propagation neural network and I'll
do this again and of course if you do
this long enough eventually the argument
will learn the perfect function how to
sort things and then the idea is a new
data item comes along and it will go to
the same function and because the
function is now perfect if you looked up
exactly the right place
no problem comes in how comes in no
problem so it's supervised because we
have labels and because with labels we
can assess the quality and in a neural
networks the classic way of doing this
and in general supervised learning is
very powerful because as long as we have
enough data with enough labels we can
always learn the function and then it
should work really well but well I
wouldn't be research for finished with
it so there's obviously a problem of
this as well the problem with this is it
you can lead to overfitting what was
overfitting mean means like tight jeans
you know know that it means that you
have too much emphasis on getting the
function right you make it too right so
the function is absolutely perfect in
fact it's so perfect it's brittle it's
it's it's just not good anymore so what
happens is a new data item comes along
one that you've not seen before I go on
and the unsupervised method wouldn't
have a problem with this because it just
goes by similarity and will go it's kind
of a light color you probably end up
here but a supervised method has never
seen this color before and the function
goes like what do I do with this and it
breaks or it puts you just in a random
place like maybe here so supervised
learning is really good but if you
overdo it then you're over fitted and
the problem is then you actually make
the system worse again you make it
brittle
the other downside of supervised
learning is you must actually have
enough data we've labeled which for some
problems you have it's fine for some
problems you don't really have it so
let's talk about a practical problem
glad was working on so I was working
with doctors in hospital clinicians who
look after colon cancer patients and
there were many years to collect the
data of about 500 patients sort of
classic medical data so we've got a each
with medical history we've got genetic
values blood values and so on and so on
and so on and they get diagnosed the
different categories of comes some more
serious some less serious and the
doctors wanted some help of this
categorization the most serious cases in
the least serious case is they're quite
clear but it's just this whole group in
the middle and I wanted to make sure can
we split them a bit better and so we
were working with this with them and so
this is a classic problem and in that
case there was 500 patients that were
already categorized as in what category
Phil missed over in so actually a
supervised approach was really good
because we could learn from those 500
and build up a picture and as long as
we're careful not overdo it up be fine
but then what actually happened this is
leads me on to what the researchers at
the moment what happened is not for all
the 500 patients did they have all the
labels because some of the technology
has been changing over the years so
there's more more than things now that I
didn't have 10 years ago so actually for
the last 50 patients they had some
additional labels that I didn't have for
all the others and so we were talking
about what to do with this and there's a
method called semi-supervised learning
which is kind of other resurfaced and
it's cancelled why can we take the best
of both worlds and maybe combined is a
bit so but if you've got a few labels
it's not enough to learn perfectly but
maybe we can do something so what we've
done is the same a supervised method and
it's kind of a mixture of the two you
get your data and let's just say we want
to split them in light and dark colors
it's
basically our more serious patients and
are less serious patients and you might
end up sorting the data something like
that because it's an unsupervised
approach first of all we don't know
exactly how good it is but then for some
of the data items we have a label and we
can look up what's the number on them
and because for some of you have a label
now we can say okay all the ones have
the same label or with a similar label
are they're in the same group so
suddenly we can assess the quality of
this so we don't have a label for all of
these but with a label for some of them
are they in the same group yes and then
the same labels are in the same group
yeah that looks like a good solution
semi-supervised learning is probably the
future because as data sets get bigger
and bigger and bigger you don't have
labels anymore for everything because
nobody has time to label everything and
computers can't really label things very
well so you'll have the experts labeling
a few things and semi-supervised
learning will be where this is going but
then next step really would be to have
it interactive that would be even better
so that's kind of what we're working on
right now it's called a man in the loop
or human in the loop learning where you
maybe have no labels at all or maybe
just very few and then you do some
sorting of the data and then we asked
you expert long you know has the sorting
gone well has it not gone well what
about this one item what would be the
label you would give it and it's sort of
a bit interactive and I think they'll be
much better because then you can you
know there is more in real time and you
can actually also latest development can
come in tacit knowledge that you might
not even have in the data so that's like
spot checking yeah exactly it's like
spot checking it and but then putting
that knowledge back into the algorithm
so the algorithm can learn from it again
and it's a sort of reinforce a lipid
that's a single-car that's basically
controlling the robot twice a 264
processes which is more than a robot
will usually get are we going now I'll
show you the big machine that's sir